for some guys they have to nut
to see if they really like the girl
right so sometimes after sex they might
be like this didn't feel right okay and
like we feel bad because we don't want
to we don't want to make you feel used
yeah okay so you answered about some
guys but what about you
[Music]
what do you want to walk in today
not a hoe i don't want someone that's
attract like entertaining 10 other guys
just simply someone i can laugh with
what i would want to walk in
tall
chocolate
handsome
caribbean or african
okay
hi hi ellie what's your name nobody okay
i love your eyes you guys are pretty
awesome thank you so much what's your
name tiana tiana nice to meet you today
uh oh you say my name again
do you tiana the accent yeah where are
you from down south west sussex okay so
everything seems like where are you from
you don't hear my accent
no where are you from not from florida
no way yeah i do apologize about the
questions i'm about to ask you all right
and that's where we start okay
what's the most embarrassing thing
that's happened to you on a date
oh
well okay so i was um on a date we were
at italian restaurant like a real
authentic italian restaurant and i
didn't know like which one was the salad
fork and which one was the yeah yeah
yeah okay
like i said i looked over i kind of
looked over here i don't think that's
that embarrassing it was embarrassing to
me i don't get embarrassed they get
embarrassed
i like that
okay yeah what's the most embarrassing
thing you've ever done uh getting
introduced to someone's parents on the
first date are you serious no i'm being
serious the parent i left straight away
that was the
so you never talked to her ever again no
she got blocked
you blocked her she blocked you no i
blocked her
you didn't want to deal with that no how
embarrassing like yeah i've been in her
i've hardly known her and her parents
already like are you mad yeah that's a
lot
all right so this next question i really
want to ask because this has been
happening to me for the past four
weeks yeah
so would you fetishize my accent
your accent
i like your accent yeah
i don't know if i'd fetishize it okay
it's definitely different obviously i
sound different to you yeah
i feel like it's attractive
it's different i prefer that i'm glad
you appreciate it
don't want to repeat yourself and go for
the same
same sounding people same looking people
you know like you're right no yeah i
like it okay yeah
what do you think of my accent it's very
calming right maybe you're talk maybe
your tone is very calming it sounds sexy
yeah you saw you should be on the
hotline yourself
i know
[Laughter]
have you ever had a whole face
it's hilarious
yes i did i feel like everybody had one
i'm so excited some people haven't some
people haven't because i've been like
relationships i know people that are 29
are still virgins yeah no that's crazy
right i don't know but there's some
people who like literally had um
relationships for a very long time they
just never had that space where they
were able to have it
i had a whole face yes i have are you
still in one right now no i'm old no
like i'm old now
25 is not old it ain't oh but it's
getting there have you had your whole
face yet
yeah yeah yeah yeah i would say i'm done
with it now for most sounds like i
enjoyed it but there's been some weird
and awkward situations where i didn't
enjoy it but i feel like that's part of
it
do you need to test the milk before
buying the cow
meaning do i need to
do you mean like do i need to have sex
with someone yeah
yeah so how important is intimacy and
dating
i feel like
it sounds bad this is going to sound bad
but with a guy sometimes for some guys
not for me but like for some guys they
have to not
to see if they really like the girl
right so sometimes after sex they might
be like this didn't feel right okay and
like we feel bad because we don't want
to we don't want to like make you feel
used yeah okay so when you talk you ask
you answered about some guys but what
about you
um
no i wouldn't say well it depends on the
person i think it's a situation as well
there has obviously has been situations
where i didn't
like the person after yeah after the
situation i mean
yeah yeah exactly
so how important is intimacy and dating
for you um
well i'm a libra
not very important but i would say like
tattoo i like it yeah
yeah but i don't think it's important on
the first date or like straight away
yeah i prefer to get to know you first
and then your insights
and then you're inside
that makes sense
also i don't want to waste my time well
it's like i get to know you we're like
two months deep into the relationship
and you're absolutely shocked in bed
dang so you're gonna dump her you know
that's what i'm saying it's a sticky one
because what if her personality is
amazing just don't have you know
i'm in the bowl no no of course i don't
think that's important but i would say
like you're not gonna teach her like
what to do um
no if she's a virgin i feel like that's
someone else's
even when they're live sometimes they
can just be like just not good they
don't
every partner i'll give it some time but
i don't think it's important yeah no i
thought like i said personality in the
way of a vibe if you can make me laugh
and you're caring
that's all i care about yeah and good
cuddles that's it good cuddles do you
rub the butt when you cuddle
like booty rubs yeah yeah
okay
what's your income
what's my income do you ask people that
on the first day oh wait no you don't
probably okay
okay i can see why okay um
i mean incomable like i don't know like
financially stable financially
financially stable i feel like yeah good
especially as a student like um a lot of
students they're still like oh no we're
going to get together
mm-hmm i have time to get together
bachelor's like that so i
yeah and they want you to take care of
them yeah well as long as they can take
care of me okay so what do you mean like
are you a 50 50 type of person like you
want the bill squiffy no no no do you
know what on the first date i'll pay the
bill okay what about life after second
yeah of course but i would like some
sort of balance i mean like sometimes
she'll like sometimes she'll say yeah
exactly like i wouldn't want to ask for
it i'm not going to ask for you to pay i
don't think i'm that type of person you
weren't hurting but yeah exactly like
majority of the times i've had that so
there was a balance in between okay but
some girls are like really in your face
and they're like pay pay pay
[Applause]
what's your income my income yeah i'd
say i'm financially disabled i have four
jobs
um
yeah yeah you financially saved me
jamaican i'm an editor i work in a
cocktail bar i want to work in a
nightclub and i work in a cafe
it's all just like i said temporarily
until like right fingers crossed acting
goes it goes that's good
so the next question
would you have sex with me
um
or would you have sex on the first date
would i have sex on the first date yeah
i would have sex with you that was two
different questions okay well answer the
first one first okay so would have sex
with you yeah
i don't know
i don't know let's see your fingernails
fingernails
i've got really chunky thumbs and things
about your thumbs and fingers
very big hands
what i'm attracted to a lot more is tall
black men african or caribbean oh yeah
yeah
but you're like the same height that my
ex boyfriend was
you have the eyes that you had except
that you turned like that color or blue
and yeah you could find me t-rex already
but when i have sex on the first date
yeah
i've done that mm-hmm
i feel like that should answer your
question right yeah would you do that
again would i do it again yeah
one night stands
it's nothing that i will like you know
return back to
but i have to doesn't feel good does
that it doesn't feel good it's just like
i know if i want to be with you or not
really honestly and then during the time
it's like okay this was just fun i
probably won't talk to everyone
that's fair enough i believe yeah yeah
would you
i would do it on the first date yeah it
depends on the person and how the date
goes
but if you
if i'm attracted to you and revive cool
no yeah yeah
okay yeah
so the questions that you have like you
know they seem pretty bold of you like
so where do they come from like where
they stem from so i struggled i'm not
glad i struggled to think of like
questions that you wouldn't ask in a
first date so i actually put up an
instagram poll two days ago
and there was some extreme questions
yeah which obviously i've skipped like
what are some what like what are some of
the wildest questions that you did get
on the phone someone told me to ask
about your periods
now you know what unless that's extra
and you know it was a female as well so
it was like
you know i don't know you're not going
to be asking like why would you ask like
why do i get it right you know what i'm
saying
she's super lovely super outgoing
definitely sassy and her accent was cool
and it wasn't that awkward to ask those
questions either so yeah it wasn't good
that was fun it was exciting i was she
was older but
it was still fun
would you like to go on another date
yeah let's go get some chicken wings in
a in a pint i don't drink beer oh okay i
don't either though so no
but we can go for like spirits like oh
yeah mixers or cocktails okay yeah yeah
i can make you some cocktails as well
because i work in a cocktail well okay
yeah yeah mixologist
it's your cocktail of choice norbert uh
probably mojito raspberry mojito oh i
love molita
yes i love the accents
same mojitos
i feel like we
clicked and had a good connection it
wasn't awkward at all felt like she made
me quite like comfortable i could see us
on a second date um you know a little
cocktails little food cause that's how
that's what i consider a real date with
some food obviously we know each other's
types but i'd say
go another date
give it a shot yeah exactly yes okay
definitely
[Music]
have you ever faked an orgasm oh my god
um yes i think if any girl who says that
they haven't they're completely lying
yeah sorry dad